montagne ruche mortel pour une femme de
35 ans cet après midi elle a été éjectée
du manège dans lequel elle avait pris
place avec son mari au parc saint paul
près de beauvais
cette mère de deux enfants est morte
d'un arrêt cardiaque selon les secours
gaïdar un gosse et gontran giraudeau la
police scientifique est déjà au travail
autour du manège
c'est sur cette attraction qu'a eu lieu
l'accident aux alentours de 16h30
une mère de famille de 35 ans est tombé
de ce dragon elle a fait une chute de
plus de 5 mètres
au sol les pompiers ont tenté de la
réanimer en vain
elle est décédée trois quarts d'heure
plus tard les circonstances du drame
restent encore inexpliquées la barre de
sécurité a bien été fermés on a entendu
deux clics de fermeture son compagnon
qui d'après là aussi entendu donc
ensuite vice et bien tourné et dans un
virage et à hauteur d'une dizaine de
mètres cette dame se trouvait éjecté de
la voiture originaire de soissons
la jeune femme était accompagnée de son
mari et de ses deux enfants
à la suite de l'accident le parc n'a été
ni fermer ni évacués un périmètre de
sécurité a été simplement établi le
manège est sous scellés pour les besoins
de l'enquêté sur place le giron ne
comprends pas ce qui a pu se passer très
clairement pour l'instant
je n'explique pas ce qui s'est passé
réellement
ce manège est récent et est contrôlé
tous les ans nos équipes techniques nous
démonter voilà tout ce qu'on sait c'est
que la personne était de forte
corpulence allait tomber ce qu elle
était mal assise
c'est peut être une possibilité car le
coaster formule 1 a déjà été inquiété
dans un incident sans gravité en juillet
un mois plus tard un autre manège le
looping avait déraillé faisant 11
blessés
ce soir le parquet de beauvais a été
saisie de l'enquêté
les